this is chapter five
it's on the concept of linear
independence
i should say it's a little bit abstract
and not that interesting
at least yet on the go on on the
positive side i would say this
actually in this book there is actually
only one mathematical concept
and this is it so the good news is
you're going to see this this is going
to be
linear independence is going to be your
friend for the rest of the book
and actually hopefully later it'll
become clear
what its importance is but for right now
just consider this
a first description of the topic so
linear independence
so we'll first describe what it means to
be linearly independent
and then we'll talk about a related
concept a very important concept called
a basis
so a set of n vectors
so here i'm using set notation that's
what those curly uh
brackets mean and this says we have a1
up to ak and
it's called a set is called linearly
dependent
if there is a linear combination
of the vectors that gives you zero now
of course
you can always make a linear combination
of the vectors to be zero if you take
the coefficients betas all the betas to
be zero
that doesn't count so it has to be a
non-zero
uh set of of coefficients that means at
least one of them is non-zero
that's what we mean here so um and
that's ex you can show that that's
exactly the same thing as saying
that one if they're dependent if a set
of vectors is dependent
it says that one of them is a linear
combination of the others
right and so in many contexts we'll see
that
something being a linear combination of
the others means that somehow it's
redundant
okay so that's the that would be the the
concept
and so if a set of vectors is dependent
it means it's like redundant
because at least one of them you could
express is a linear combination of the
others
of course that depends on the
application but that's the idea okay
and the way uh now the correct way to
say it
is the set of n vectors
is linearly dependent right
because a set is a in english it's a
it's not plural it's singular and so you
say it is linearly
dependent now people get sloppy um and
not that sloppy to
tell you tell you the truth this is just
standard uh sort of mathematical uh
convention but what people do is they
say a 1 through a k
are linearly dependent um and you have
to be very careful because
that's just that's just the way people
say it and um
it's technically not quite right okay
that's fine so
let's look at some examples well if i
have a set that consists of a single
vector
oh by the way it doesn't hurt you to
know this a set with one element is
called a singleton
so that's a this is a set of vectors
there's only one
and it's a1 so when is that linearly
dependent
well the question is when can i make a
linear combination of one entry
zero with a non-zero
coefficient well that's only if a1 is 0.
in which case i can take any beta i like
here's one beta
beta 1 in that case equals 2 there okay
so 2 times 0 is 0. okay so basically for
a singleton for a single vector linear
and
linear dependence is like being zero
okay
so okay um if i have two
linearly if they're linearly dependent
so
the set with two entries a one and a two
is linearly dependent
only if one of them is a multiple of the
other okay
and so that means actually they lie on
the same line roughly speaking
okay so that's what that means now for
more than two vectors
there's no simple to state condition
right like i can't tell you that for
four vectors
they're dependent if blah blah blah it's
complicated
uh we will see later uh an algorithm
uh that will take a set of vectors and
we'll
process them and tell you in the end if
they're linearly dependent
or not so so we'll we'll be able to to
uh
to check that but it's a computational
thing it's not something you can do
okay by just looking at it i mean it
depends right
okay so let's look at some examples um
here's some there's three three vectors
a1 a2
and a3 um and
it turns out in this case here's a
linear combination with non-zero
coefficients the coefficients are one
two and minus three and you can check
that a1 plus two a2
minus three a3 is zero
there so that means these vectors
are linearly dependent right um or to
say it very precisely
this set of three vectors is linearly
dependent
okay and what this says is you can
express
um in this case you can express any of
these vectors as a linear combination of
the others
so for example let's express a2 as a
linear combination of a1 and a3
well here a2 uh what i do is i take this
equation the this equation and i put
a 3 and a 1 on the other side and i
divide by 2
and i get this this expression here
right so
and in this case i can also express a
a1 as a linear combination of a2 and a3
and i can express a3
as a linear combination of a1 and a2
okay so so that's what it means it
simply means these are dependent
and one of the vectors in this case all
three can be expressed as linear
combinations of the others
okay now in some applications
a linear dependence you know has a
meaning and it also may have a different
name
so for example if you have cash flows
uh if your vectors represent cash flows
of investments or something like that
or some kind of investment or some you
know it could be a loan or a
bond payment it doesn't matter a
mortgage
so these are these are cash flows and
there uh
when you when one one of those cash
flows is a linear combination of the
others in finance people would say
you have replicated that cash flow
i don't remember if you remember like a
very a long time ago we looked at
uh you can replicate a
you know a a two-period loan you know
as a linear you can represent as a
linear combination of two
one-period loans so then you would say
that
you have replicated that the two-period
loan cash flow okay so so in different
in different in different areas
uh specific applications there'll be
other names for linear dependence okay
but
right now i should also just fully admit
that
this should look abstract weird and
utterly uninteresting to you if that's
what you're thinking right now then
that's fully justified so hopefully that
won't be the case in a couple of weeks
or
certainly by the time we finish the book
this should be uh this should be natural
to you and stuff like that but for now
right now
you're looking at this and saying like
who who could care less
and i all i want to say is that's a
perfectly good question
okay now if you're if a set of vectors
is not linearly dependent
uh they are linearly independent so and
that
that's actually the concept we really
need it's linear independence
um and so a set of n vectors here
is linearly independent if it's not
linearly dependent
and so what that means is this it says
one way to say it is this
is it says that if you have a linear
combination
of those vectors and you get zero right
so
if you if you can make zero with a
linear combination the
only way to do that is if all the betas
are zero
right for any vectors at all if i make a
linear combination of all zero
coefficients i get zero so i can always
make a linear combination zero i just
take all the bases e zero
question is whether or not i can do it
with non-zero coefficients
and so um and that says that if they are
if the set of vectors is linearly
independent um
i can't do it the only way to have
a linear combination come up to zero is
that
uh all the coefficients are zero okay um
and again here people say you know the
vectors are linearly independent
instead of the set of vectors is
linearly independent
but by the way if you're around fancy
mathematicians and if you
are being careful and you say this set
of vectors is linearly independent
they'll smile um they're not they're
they're not that
emotive but anyway i'm just saying that
your status will go up
maybe you won't you won't be able to
tell but it will go up okay all right
um and basically that says that not one
of these vectors can be represented as a
linear combination of the others that's
another way to say it
so here's an example let's uh the let's
take the
unit the n unit and vectors they are
linearly
independent how do you know that
well you ask yourself if i had a linear
combination of the unit vectors and it
was zero
but then you can quickly figure out all
the coefficients have to be zero and
that's what it means to be linearly
independent okay
this will be the first hint that this
might be a useful concept it's
it's quite interesting here it is
suppose you have a vector
x and suppose i tell you it is a linear
combination
of some vectors a 1 through a k and
let's suppose those vectors
or that set of vectors to say precisely
is linearly independent
so that means that x is beta 1 a 1
plus up to beta k ak okay that that's
what it means to be a linear combination
so here's what's cool about it in this
case the way you'd say it in math is
you'd say
the coefficients beta 1 up to beta k are
unique
um and that's a what that means is this
if x suppose x had a representation as
an a different representation so here i
i've written
x as a linear combination with a set of
coefficients gamma 1 up to gamma k
then what we're saying is if that's true
the only way that's true
is if gamma 1 is beta 1 gamma 2 is
beta 2 and gamma k is beta k so
um so what's what's cool what this means
is that we don't know how to do it yet
but we will later
but it says that in principle you can
deduce the coefficients
from the vector so uh i'll say this this
is weird but it says you can actually
decompose if you have if x is a linear
combination of some linearly independent
vectors
i can actually i can actually discover
the in principle i can discover those
coefficients there's only one way to do
it
um that's actually super interesting and
and later in the class we'll get
we'll you'll see exactly how to do that
uh but for now
we're just and all you need is the
concept of linear independence to
to argue that you can do this um
okay now why would that be well suppose
x has that expansion it's a linear
combination with the betas but it's also
linear combination with the gammas
so what i'm going to do is i am
going to subtract this
from that and here's what i'm going to
get
i'm going to get beta 1 minus gamma 1
times a1
up to this and and that's going to be 0
because the right hand side is going to
be x minus x this is
0 over here okay now you look at this
and you realize like wow
this is a linear this is a linear
combination of a1
up to ak the coefficients are beta 1
minus gamma 1 up to beta k minus gamma k
and you get 0 but if they're linearly
independent
what it says is if you have a linear
combination
that gets you zero then all the
coefficients have to be zero and that
means that all of these numbers beta one
minus gamma one all the way up to beta k
minus gamma k they're all zero
and that just means that the betas are
the gammas
okay so that's called it has a a unique
representation
as a uh as a linear combination
okay or another way to say it is in
principle if something is a linear
combination
there's only one way it's a linear
combination not only that
but we can actually deduce what those
coefficients are
in principle we don't know a way to do
it yet but we will later
okay this leads us to something that's a
super important concept um again
for now it's abstract um but we're going
to be using these things throughout the
rest of the book so
might as well get used to it just
consider this your first your
introduction
so and it's the concept of basis um
so uh we start with a very
um well okay some people call it
fundament
some people actually call it the
fundamental theorem of linear algebra or
something i don't know
i i that's overblown um it is
it and it's not even that hard to show
if you look in the book i'm not going to
show it but if you look in the book
it's like a two-thirds or half a page
proof
of this um but much less important than
the proof
is actually just what it says and here's
what it says it's very simple it says
if you have a linearly independent set
of n vectors
you could have at most n of them
another way to say it is this if you
have n plus
one or more n vectors they are linearly
dependent okay so that's and
uh you know even it it's it's not
obvious
uh but it's it it's actually kind of
true it's interesting right so it says
that if i have
uh 12 10 vectors
then i absolutely guarantee you one of
those
at least one i can write as a linear
combination of the others
okay so or i could say they are linearly
dependent
okay um that's that that's how that
works
and it's actually kind of kind of
interesting
right um so okay so that that's that's
it
and that's a that's called the
independence dimension inequality right
because
basically it says that a set of linearly
independent vectors
has us if they're n vectors that set can
never be bigger
can never have more than n elements in
it that's what it means
okay so right now this is totally
abstract but that's okay
okay now this gets us to basis if i have
a set of
n linearly independent n vectors
that's a1 through a1 that's called a
basis
uh this is like completely universal
standard mathematical notation um
okay so what it says then
is any n vector say b can be expressed
as a linear combination of them
okay for some beta 1 up to beta n
and not only that but those coefficients
are unique uh they're not there's no
other way you can do that that follows
from linear
independence now
this formula here in that context when
a1 up to a n is a basis
that's called the expansion of b in the
a1 dot
dot a-n basis okay so
um i mean expansion okay kind of makes
sense that you were we're taking b
here and we're kind of writing it as a
linear combination and the old world
19th century term for that
is it's the expansion in the in the ai
basis
okay um so here's an example i mean this
is completely pedantic and silly because
it's completely obvious but here's an
example
uh e1 up to en those are the standard
unit vectors that's a basis
and here's the expansion of a vector in
the unit vector basis i mean this is
silly
it says it says b is b1 e1 plus up to b
and en
well we already know that and plus it's
completely obvious
right so but it's just an exam just an
example of a basis and an
expansion in a basis
okay next topic is
orthonormal vectors we'll talk about
that's also going to play a big role
in the in actually the rest of the
material in the book
so uh and we'll we'll see what they are
um so a set of vectors uh a1 through ak
are said to be mutually orthogonal or
just orthogonal
if any pair of them that has to be
distinct right
um are orthogonal right so this says
that a i
that if you recall that little this
little symbol here
which is by the way sometimes read in
english as perp for perpendicular
this says that a i is perpendicular to a
j
and remember that's a that's another
that's one of the ways we say orthogonal
and of course
all this means is that the inner product
of a i
and aj is zero that's that's all that
means
so that's what it means um a set of
vectors is called
uh normalized if they have length one
right uh so it just means they're
normalized they're not like some of them
are big and some are small they're all
the same size in fact
specifically size one okay then they're
called normalized
and a set of vectors is called
orthonormal if both hold
so what that means is uh two things it
means that
any pair any pair of them uh any
distinct pair right
you can't have i naughty i equal to j
any distinct pair of the vectors
has an angle of 90 degrees that's number
one that's they're orthogonal
and number two each of those each each
vector has a norm
or length of one okay so that that's
orthonormal
and you can write that just in terms of
the inner products what it says is
a set of vectors is orthonormal if the
following is true
if i take an inner product of the i
factor with the jth vector
i get either one if i equals j because
the inner product of a vector with
itself is its norm squared
and if it's normalized that's that's one
squared which is one
on the other hand if i is not equal to j
a i
uh the inner product of a i of a i and
aj is zero and that expresses the fact
that they are orthogonal
okay so so what it is it's a way to say
that the inner products between the
entries you know
have very simple and very specific
number they're very specific and simple
numbers
okay now uh we're going to see later
that orthonormal
sets of vectors are linearly um
independent um
and that's a quick calculation we're
going to see much more about it later
in fact what we're going to find out is
you can actually get the coefficient you
can actually say what the coefficients
are in an expansion
and obviously by the independence
dimension inequality
you can't have more than n or their
normal
n vectors you can't have n but you can't
have more
and when k is equal to n so i have
n n vectors and they are orthonormal
they're called an orthonormal basis
that's the that's the idea and this is
very very common
across lots of fields of applied
mathematics and other areas
okay so let's look at some examples well
we've already seen this the
the standard unit vectors uh they have
they have norm one they're
all each one has norm one uh because the
n the norm square the
sum of the squares the entries of each
of these is one because all entries are
zero one is one
square one okay you get it so they all
have normal one they're normalized
and they're also orthogonal if i take
any two unit vectors
diff for different i and j then
inner product of e i and e j is zero
because the ones are in the different
positions and everything else is zero
okay here's an example of an
orthonormal basis um in
in in for three-dimensional uh vectors
and
here they are it's the the first vector
is zero zero minus one
it's normalized the second one is one
over square root two one one zero
okay let's check uh let's get let's take
the norm of that in our head or
let's take this so you put the one over
square root two inside right and you
square it so the first you square
the first entry is going to be a half
half zero
add up the sum of the squares you get
one take the square root of that you get
one
so it's also normalized and here's our
third one it looks like that
okay and you can also check it is
normalized let's check let's just audit
a few inner products just for fun
well let's do the inner product of this
guy and that one
well what you can see is when you take
the pairwise products
there's a zero this is zero here so that
first entry
is zero then that's zero and that's zero
so it's zero
how about these two these two here let's
do that
well i multiply this one and this one
and i get
one uh if you like we could add the one
over square root of two so i would get a
half okay
in the first entry and the next one i
get minus a half
and then the last one i get 0 and i add
these up and i get 0
so they are orthogonal these two vectors
are orthogonal
visually uh here's here here is here
here's two two vectors
um and they are orthonormal i mean i i
assume that i'm assuming here the length
of that is one
right and the length of that is one um
but that's what it means it means they
both have length 1
and that's the origin and
they are they have 90 degree angle
between them so this is what an
orthonormal basis looks like
it's okay it's easy to you can also
visualize an orthonormal basis in three
dimensions
you cannot visualize it in 10 dimensions
right you can pretend you
you can pretend to but you're lying
basically
so you know if there's if you're around
people who don't know anymore
you can actually like impress them
incredibly you just say well look you
know what this looks like here
this is two orthonormal things three
things you know you can make a little
hand
document your hand thing and kind of get
your fingers in the
approximately orthonormal and and then
you can say okay well
the same thing only just in 10
dimensions that's not that hard
anyway of course people can't can't
really visualize that
okay this brings us to the concept of an
orthonormal expansion
so suppose i have an orthonormal basis
a1 through a n
then it says the following we have for
any n vector x
i can write it this way now we knew
because it was a basis we could write it
as a linear combination of a 1 through a
n we knew that
but now we're going to be super specific
about what the coefficients are
they are in fact the inner product of a1
and x all the way up to the inner
product of a n
and x so this this is what we call the
orthonormal expansion of x
you know in some orthonormal basis okay
now
if you want to check this formula let's
do the following let's just take the
inner pro
let's just write we know that x must
have the form
because it's a basis it's got to have
the form
like that looks like this of
like that okay so we know it's a oh god
what have i done okay here we go there's
a those are a's
my mistake okay so um so we know that
because
because it's a basis any vector x
is a linear combination but we don't
know the coefficients beta
beta i okay so let's take the inner
product of
left and right hand sides of this
equality with let's say
a1 and it's going to be similar for the
others so on the left i get the inner
product of a1 and x and on the left i
get the inner product of
beta 1 a1 and a1
that's beta 1 times the inner product of
a1 and a1
but these are orthonormal so that's one
okay
now how about the inner product of
a1 and the and the second term which is
bay 2
beta 2 a2 well that's beta 2
if i take the inner product like that
that's gonna i can put this inside and i
get a one
uh the inner product of a1 and a2 like
that and
this is zero by uh normality
uh sorry uh by orthogonality right so
that's zero
and so all the other terms here are zero
and you just get
beta so it says a1 transpose x is beta
1 right so that tells us that beta 1 is
a1 transpose x
so that's that's the calculation it's
pretty pretty simple
again at the moment this should be
completely abstract and weird i mean you
may have seen in another class
and i you know i don't know the context
right but you may have seen this in
another class
but if you haven't and this looks like
it's weird and abstract and has
no particular interest to you that's a
perfectly normal feeling to have